Norman - Sur le site de la SPA, j'ai repéré un petit chat pour lequel j'ai eu un vrai p'tit coup de coeur
Norman - Simplement, il ne se trouve pas à Paris,
Norman - il se trouve dans une SPA qui est à Étalondes, à quelque heures de Paris,
Norman - Et bah aujourd'hui, il est 8 heures du mat' et on va le chercher.
Blanche - "rire", Non ça va me faire une tête de poisson.
Norman - Pour accueillir ce nouveau chat j'ai acheté quelques accessoires,
Norman - histoire de la mettre ienb'
Norman - Cette petite heu.... canne à pêche à chat,
Norman - Des petites couches, "En répondant à quelqu'un" : Bonsoir.
Norman - Petits caramels et tous.
Norman - Les petites croquettes...
Norman - Si avec ça il n'est pas content......on peut le piquer.
Norman - Il va être accueilli comme un petit prince.
Norman - Donc là on est à Amiens, petit changement.
Norman - Alors là j'ai envie de filmer blanche en train de démarrer la voiture,
Norman - Parce que c'est vraiment le même personnage que dans ma dernière vidéo.
Norman - C'est à dire la personne qui conduit une fois tous les 8 ans.
Homme - Alors, comment on démarre...
Blanche - Alors, c'est une essence...
Norman - Oh Putain...
Norman - Okay, woah woah !
Blanche - Qu'est-ce que ça fait, pourquoi ça dit ça ?
Norman - Putain, c'est ma ceinture, calme toi !
Blanche - Mets ta ceinture !
Norman - La meuf elle est tendue au maximum !
Blanche - Arrête !
Norman - Alors là on quitte Amiens pour aller à Étalondes, là où se trouve la SPA.
Norman - On aura vraiment fait le parcours du combattant pour récupérer ce chat.
Norman - Mais j'ai eu ce petit coup de cœur donc on va jusqu'au bout du délire.
Norman - Le vent souffle, un truc de ouf.
Norman - La voiture siffle.
"La voiture siffle"
Norman - Ça siffle !
Norman - On va peut-être s'envoler.
Norman - Vu le vent qu'on a depuis tout à l'heure, si on avait un voilier, on irait hyper vite.
Norman - Ici y'a du fumier, des éoliennes, la forêt je pense qu'on va atterrir dans une ferme
Norman - Nous croisons une voiture, après 1H de route en solitaire.
Norman - Plus que 530m
Norman - La bonne forêt !
Norman - Après 5H de trajet, on arrive enfin à la SPA.
"♫Musique de réussite♫"
"Il toque"
"Ils se disent bonjour"
Norman - Norman enchanté.
Nathalie - Nathalie enchantée.
Norman - Je viens pour le petit chat.
"♫Musique mignonne♫"
Norman - Les yeux très bleus.
Ohhh !
Norman - Bonjour, je possède toutes les couleurs des chats.
Norman - Oh, il ronronne !
"Le chat ronronne"
"♫Musique curieuse♫"
Norman - On dirait vraiment Garfield. Et moi tu me griffes ou pas? Il s'en bat les couilles !
Nathalie - Et le chat que vous aimez bien donc c'est celui là.
"♫Musique d'aventure♫"
POUM !
"♫Musique mignonne♫"
Norman - Premier contact plutôt raté.
Norman - Pas encore de ronron,
Norman - Au moins il ne me griffe pas.
Norman - Oh la la, le feeling est présent.
"Il rit"
Norman - Bah alors...
Une femme - Il risque de se cacher le premier jour mais voilà.
Norman - La première année il se cache un peu.
Le reste - NON !!
"♫Musique triste♫"
"♫Musique mignonne♫"
Norman - J'ai capturé un Pokemon !
"♫Générique Pokemon♫"
Norman - Je te capture pour une vie mieux, es-tu content ?
"Ils se disent au revoir"
"♫Musique mignonne♫"
Norman - J'ai récupéré le petit chat à la SPA, il a deux ans,
Norman - Il est extrêmement mignon, un peu timide, tendu, mais je sens qu'il est plein d'affections.
Norman - Pour l'instant il a juste un projet c'est de fuir vers l'infini.
Norman - Mais on va lui montrer qu'on est des gens biens et qu'il peut nous faire confiance.
Norman - Un peu d'eau
Norman - Prêt pour la route ?
Norman - "Il rit" Merde, bah alors petit lapin...
Norman - On sort de la SPA, on est resté bien 2H avec les chats,
Norman - C'est un petit peu difficile parce qu'on a envie de tous les adopter, mais c'est impossible.
Norman - Maintenant il ne reste plus qu'à faire la dernière étape, rester en vie alors que Blanche conduit jusqu'à Paris pendant 3h.
Blanche - Tout va très bien se passer !
Norman - On n'a pas encore entendu la voix du chat
Norman - Ça se trouve il va faire : "Avec une voix grave" Miaou, miaou miaou.
Norman - Je suis sur une aire d'autoroute, j'ai mis des gants pour nettoyer la gamelle en toute propreté,
Norman - mais on dirait vraiment que je vais lui faire un toucher rectale.
Norman - BAHHH !
Norman - Merlin, "Il l'appelle", tu va "biene"?
Norman - Il ne reste plus qu'une heure après tu vas être pépouze.
"Merlin ronronne"
Norman - Coucou Merlin.
"♫Jazz♫"
Norman - Tu donne des coups de boule à la caméra?
Norman - Ouiiii, ahah.
"♫Musique mignonne♫"